so check I have located my stationary
points there's the first one right there
and then there's the second one but I
don't know what kind they I could be it
could be any of these right how do I do
this okay now as you're going to
discover there's more than one way to
actually solve this next question of
determining the nature but all I want to
do is just use the tools we have at our
disposal now just look more carefully of
these guys right do you ever said to you
before oh how can we describe what's
happening well for this guy it's
decreasing then it stops and then it's
increasing yeah that's how you can tell
that's what it looks like and this is
the opposite right it's increasing then
it's decreasing
like that's how you would tell the
difference between these what can you
tell me about this one what's the
derivative gonna be doing before and
after that stationary point positive
then zero then positive again and then
here it's the opposite its negative and
then negative so based on this and maybe
you want to drop this on the side in
different color right I'm gonna use this
space down here okay if I go positive
then it's zero then it's negative which
one of those is it have a look
positive then it's zero then it's
negative which which one is it it's the
upside-down parabola right now what that
means is the stationary point we found
it's at the top of the function it's at
the top so we call this we call this
configuration a maximum it's like that's
the highest you can go in this little
vicinity okay so this is a maximum well
if I switch the order what if it was
negative then zero then positive which
one of those is a
it's it's the regular looking parabola
it's this guy right decreasing zero
increasing this is not a maximum it's a
minimum right so I'm looking at what's
the derivative doing just to the left
and just to the right okay now because I
know what kind of function this is I'm
just going to pause there we'll visit
those other guys on the left hand side
there honestly you know enough to
actually be able to complete this
situation for those particular ones on
left hand side I'm just gonna hit pause
on them for now I'm going to tell you
right now just to make things a bit
simpler for this example these guys are
either going to be a maximum or a
minimum and I just need to find out
which one it is I need to sort of look
around the stationary point and see
what's going on okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to test values of the derivative okay
the easiest way to lay this out in a
systematic way is to draw up a table of
values for dy and DX we're going to draw
up a table of values for dy and DX we
need particular values of X and then the
values of the derivative for those X
values okay and I just need to know
what's happening on the left and what's
happening on the right so for this guy
here what's a value a little bit to the
left of negative two how about negative
three that's the bit to the left right
we know what's happening at negative two
what's a little bit to the right and
negative haven't negative 1 right this
is just the left just to the right now
I'm actually going to put an asterisk on
these we're going to come back to these
values later because you'll see you
actually have to be quite careful with
your selection of these but for now to
keep the examples simple let's have a go
at just this because it will do the job
for us okay we've already done some of
this we know the derivative is zero at
negative two but now what I'd like you
to do is go to the derivative this guy
here mmm there it is x squared minus 4
can you pop in these two values for me
please and then tell me
what values you get is a five because
it's uh it's nine minus four so that's
five how about this one negative three
so which one is it well it's maximum
right positive zero fair [ __ ]
you can even visualize this for you
right what does the gradient look like
it's increasing then it's stationary
it's flat and then it's decreasing you
can even see the maximum shape right
there okay
say that's right oh yeah because I've
separated them in so therefore I would
say see this guy here right I can say
based on this table of values therefore
negative 2 comma 16 over 3 is a will
have zoomed in too far it's a maximum
turning point that's what I call it that
is the nature of the stationary point
this is a maximum so any point can I ask
you please to repeat this process dry
yourself up another tiny little table
but do it for the other turning point
okay do it for this guy you want to find
a value just to the left a value just to
the right you can determine them
yourself and then draw up your table
values accordingly go ahead and do that
for me please because what you've got is
x squared minus 4 is your derivative
right when you try it out your values
correct me if I'm wrong I think you just
get them in reverse order
yeah did you get that already okay so in
the same way you can be like oh it's
decreasing then it's horizontal then
it's increasing this is a minimum
turning point so I would say therefore 2
comma 16 yes said again sorry hey you
talked about that one over there
okay so it's a maximum because yeah you
go up then you stop and then you come
back down which is but it's like imagine
a roller coaster right as you hit the
top and then you started going down so
that means it's a maximum you're right
at the very top of it at least in that
little area okay and we said checking
code this is a minim
because it's the bottom it's the bottom
of a valley if you're like you think
it's a minimum turning point okay now
will you stop there okay but I will
quickly show you what it looks like and
you might want to do this yourself what
was the function I gave you I think was
X cubed divided by 3 - that's right I
need the whole thing
laughs divide it there we go - 4 X right
yeah
there we go okay can you guys see that
okay all right now remember I told you
that I put an asterisk on these right
and I said hey be careful okay and
actually more we kind of picked up on
this right negative 3 where is that at
some yeah right negative 3 it's to the
left of this maximum so anyway and then
negative 1 is to the right okay but I
hope you can imagine that I could have
given you a different function to begin
with and these turning points could
actually been really close together like
they're closer than negative 2 & 2
that's actually quite spread out right
imagine if the two turning points right
next to each other right right next to
each other then when you pick your
values if you went too far right then
you would not see this kind of behavior
you're like oh no I've got positive or
negative I'm not getting what I'm
expecting you actually have to be quite
close I would recommend and this is
tricky because it's a bit of a blurry
sort of thing I'll recommend trying to
get to this as close as you can without
making it awkward for yourself so for
example negative whoops no sorry
negative two point one and negative one
point nine they would be even closer do
you agree right so I can have greater
certainty that I'm gonna get you know in
the neighborhood of this value but even
then like I could artificially
manufacture some weird function where
everything was super super compressed
and even these would not be enough so it
con depends on your function I knew that
these would be okay because I knew where
the stationary points were right